arriving at Court Cardinal George Pell
was taken in through a door away from
the waiting crowds there was no room
inside for everyone the court packed
with other survivors of abuse by the
Catholic Church and Pell supporters o
angel inside the verdict was that Pelt
appeal had failed and a six-year jail
term for abuse and to choirboys when he
was Archbishop of Melbourne in the 90s
would stand Justice Maxwell and I
accepted the prosecution's submission
that the complainant was a very
compelling witness was clearly not a
liar was not a fantasy cyst and was a
witness of truth Pal is the
highest-ranking Catholic worldwide to be
convicted of child sex offenses he was
once the Vatican's treasurer and one of
the Pope's closest advisors his lawyers
had argued that the jury's verdict was
unreasonable based on the evidence and
that the jury relied too much on the
account of the only surviving victim
through his lawyer that victim said he
was relieved by the court's decision it
is four years since I reported to the
police the criminal process has been
stressful the journey has taken me to
places that in my darkest moments I
feared I would not return from as
survivors we are now also being heard
believed and we have now
the glorious day for us and surviving
the Vatican has acknowledged the
decision and says it's committed to
pursuing those who've broken the law as
the proceedings continue to develop the
Holy See recalls that the Cardinal has
always maintained his innocence
throughout the judicial process and it
is his right to appeal to the High Court
but survivors advocates say the Catholic
Church needs to prove its taking clergy
abuse seriously you think of all the
children who were abused who had crimes
committed on them in Catholic orphanages
and children's homes and you think they
won't they never got justed and they'll
never get their day in court he is going
to rot in a Cell he will then rot in
hell and I say farewell pal pal won't be
eligible for parole until 2022 when he's
81 alexei o'brien al jazeera